for Best Original Screenplay the
nominees are Guillaume Laura and John
Pierre janay for Amelie Julian Fellowes
for Gosford Park Christopher Nolan and
Jonathan Nolan from the Mentos Milo
Atika and well locals for monsters by
Wes Anderson and Owen Wilson for The
Royal Tenenbaums
and the Oscar goes to Julian Fellowes
the gospel park
this is the first hospice with Julian
Fellowes and his first for the
screenplay he was voted one of writing
ten screenwriters to watch
I think I'll hold this I don't wanna let
go of it now oh I feel as if I'm in a
star is born
any minute now Norman mains gonna come
out and whack me in the mouth oh well
obviously my thanks start with the great
Robert Altman who's given me the biggest
break in the movies since Lana Turner
walked into Schwab's and then Scott
Greenstein and USA Capitol films
Eileen Maisel who told me to write Bob
Balaban who got me the job Kathy King
Duncan Heath Ronny Jason and of course
my terrific son Peregrine and my wife
the beautiful Emma who has a lot to put
up with when I'm not working I mean
moody and difficult and then when I
start on a new job I change into someone
who's even more mean moody and difficult
but finally I want to thank the Academy
and all of you for your tradition of
kindness to foreigners like myself I
think you must be the most generous
nation on earth so thank you very much
and God bless america
you